road to zero
the impact of crashes
in 2020
318 people were killed and almost two
and a half thousand seriously injured on
new zealand's roads
we need to start doing things
differently everyone should be able to
get to where they're going safely
whether they're walking cycling driving
on a motorbike or using public transport
some members of our community see the
impacts that crashes can have way too
often
hi i'm kim munro i am a senior press
constable based in the rangara area i'm
attached to the strategic traffic unit
i've been with the police for 17 years
over the years i've dealt with several
crashes and a lot of them have been
quite serious and even resulting in
death the impact of dealing with
families is huge we are all human and we
do make mistakes but unfortunately those
mistakes
can have devastating effects
so i lost my family in a fatal crash
many years ago when i was six years old
so it's had a huge impact on my life
and now i like to
give back and try and help other people
not go through those consequences
we do or make mistakes but things like
taking your time on the roads wearing
your seat belt not driving impaired not
driving with alcohol or drugs and also
putting that cell phone down would make
a huge difference
so none of us want to be the reason for
a crash we can all help each other out
by being a little bit more patient
and courteous on the road and just take
that extra time
we all need to look out for each other
no one wants to be the reason someone
gets hurt on our roads
we can all make a difference
[Music]